tom brady sent out a um put out like a
tweet and an instagram right about
sonny's contract yeah he did
there it is in pursuit of eight lfg
buccaneers we're gonna keep the brand
together and here to tell us what lfg
stands for is none other than tom curran
of nbc sports boston
right tom is that what you're here to
tell us that stands for looking for
gumdrops
that was a spinning curve in the zone
and you hit it out well done tom
yup how are you doing
i know i'm i'm already on that i'm
already on it so
so um if i told you a year ago when
we're all wondering where's tom
going he's not only going to be a
buccaneer but he's going to win a
championship in his first year of the
buccaneers he's going to sign a contract
extension
to uh to make it a more cap friendly
moment for his team and
and and be a quarterback at age 45. you
would have said what tom you believed it
right
i would have said i know right right i
mean
i mean i really had i had them 13 and 3
and winning the super bowl this year and
that was
before the season began i just he was
too good now honestly
we're seeing the reasons
that tom brady didn't look like a player
on the rise
born out in the last 18 months here in
new england
um you know cam newton's coming back why
is kim newton coming back cameron's
coming back because the patriots say
it wasn't his fault it wasn't on him it
was beyond cam's control we haven't done
a great job
surrounding this any quarterback with
good enough players
so we're going to do a better job of it
cam come on back we'll do better this
year
and that's what brady was working with
so i still knew he had skill to do
what he's doing it as for i mean i
really thought
43 was gonna be it but 43 has come and
gone
and there is no sign of slowing down so
as far as brady goes just same as it
ever was huh
so before we move on to cam uh we were
discussing yesterday just
kind of having fun as brady figured it
out uh i mean the answer is obviously
yes but the question i posed is that
does he figured it out by
not going for the dak deal insisting on
the
mahomes deal or watson deal or goff deal
or wentz deal and taking less
and and and winning that way and now
here he is extending he's
he's not taking leslie but he's not
asking for more
as a matter of fact he's reconfiguring
so the other guys can be gotten
in the fold did brady ever at any point
in time sit there and think
i i demand that deal and then think
twice about her or the patriots said no
and then he had to go in this direction
can you walk me through this whole
scenario of brady
doing this year in and year out tom sure
in in 2010 he wanted to be paid top of
market
and he eventually was i think it was
six and sixty i might be wrong but it
was
it was a lot and it put him at the top
of the market and he stayed there
and then in 2013 that's when craft said
we wanted to come up with an elegant
solution
to tom's contract so that we could
reconfigure it
so that's when brady began taking less
and agreed to an extension that took him
to 17
um through 17 and then 18 and 19 those
extensions
so that's when brady started to say okay
if you're not gonna
if you want to go year to year with me
you don't want to give me the surety
that i'm going to be here long term
you want to play footsie with jimmy
garoppolo while also keeping me appeased
and on on the string then i'm going to
want to be paid more
and that's when he started to ask for a
little bit more but during the
2013 the 2018 span
especially after they brought in
garoppolo he's like i'll play ball for
less
to make sure i stay in new england so
what he's doing right now in tampa
is basically what he did do in new
england
in the arts and also in the middle of
this past decade
and i think it's really just a he felt
that was a good faith negotiation and i
know
specifically and you can you've read
about it he didn't feel as if the
patriots were necessarily
negotiating in good faith with him from
2018 on
so uh tom curran nbc sports boston
patriots insider here on the rich eisen
show
so then what do you think the belichick
philosophy is going to be
at quarterback since obviously there's
only as my
buddy chris brockman said earlier on
brady's a one-of-one there's only one
subset of
of tb-12 where you know
when he does get paid top of market
you're at a point of time in
in in the nfl food chain if you will
in 2010 before the new collective
bargaining agreement where
six and sixty if that's in fact right
around the neighborhood
that that's that's one and a half years
of of dak prescott's current four-year
deal that he just made
uh what is their philosophy going to be
just uh
go and draft one while cam hopefully
continues to win or hope that cam is
that guy
like what do you think their philosophy
is going to be to try and build this
thing back
for new england tom i think
as you've heard before people say
sometimes not making a decision
is making a decision and the cam newton
thing that's a placeholder that's a cya
move
in case nobody else shakes loose at
least we had cam in place
in early march so that we could say when
free agency began
yes we have a player his name is cam
newton didn't look great last year but
you're going to be part of the reason he
looks better this year
but as for what would happen because it
is a reasonable contract
especially when you prorated over two
years say he makes
nine million over two years if he
doesn't become the starter here
it's very reasonable for for cam
newton's services
so they can also still wait for a jimmy
garoppolo to shake loose from the tree
or
sam darnold we see what kind of dominoes
fall post
uh desean watson if that makes any kind
of a
you know his movement there but
basically to me rich announces
no thank you on ryan patrick appreciate
it but no thanks also on mitch trubisky
we would prefer not to have you know
alex smith
all those players of that ilk have now
been passed on
in favor of cam newton if nothing else
shakes free
well we'll see how it goes but i just
don't think that the plan
really has crystallized for them because
they don't control
their own destiny so to speak they can't
guarantee for instance
that if i put this package together i
can go get trail ants
and they can't go to the niners and say
we're gonna give you this package for
jimmy garoppolo because they're gonna
look at him and say
what are we supposed to do we don't know
if we're gonna get kirk cousins or
deshaun watson
or anybody else so it's kind of a
waiting game i think
so it's a draft day or draft days
uh scenario of domino tumbling is what
you're saying so
do you think new england's sitting there
at 15 look they're not
i can't imagine what the package would
have to be for the jets to say yes to
them or the dolphins are two and three
right so
right let's let's let's aim a little
lower do they do they go
and and move up if they love justin
fields or they love
land uh you know uh wilson i mean
um that doesn't sound like new england
but then again they've had brady for 20
years so we don't know
what their what their philosophy really
is i've spoken to about this you know
people who've been in the organization
and are in the organization i said look
bill has
won with a sixth round pick he replaced
bernie kozar who would have been the
number one overall pick back in
the early 90s late 80s he replaced him
with a retread
vinnie testaverde he won with a seventh
round pick in matt castle he developed a
second round pick from division two and
jimmy garoppolo he developed
for set why is he gonna go and jump into
the top ten
and they said well we don't know he's
not gonna do that because he's always
had tom
so folks close to bill who know the way
he thinks don't think
that he is averse to going up
my contention as you look at the new
england patriots is
you've done so poorly in the draft
at wide receiver and tight end you've
either ignored it
or swung and missed so frequently in the
last six to seven years
and in free agency you can't be giving
away draft picks
at this juncture their front seven
doesn't scare anybody
they might lose steph gilmore they don't
have any wide receivers
they drafted two tight ends neither of
whom is going to move the needle
it's just i don't think it's a great
idea to go get matt jones or trey lance
and give up the collateral that you'll
have to because the holes
need filling now
so uh tom curran here on the rich hazard
show so this oh call my guy
no no no no because i thought you said
now i thought that was a pivot to
another statement
i just honestly that's what i thought uh
no no that's all good you know it's all
good it's all good that was it was like
an offsides but we can continue with the
play like aaron rodgers not a problem
so um so so you mentioned earlier in the
conversation that uh
it's not cam's fault we're gonna you
know and we'll tell free agents you're
gonna be part of the reason why cam's
gonna look better
so what what will they do will they be
aggressive and what
what do you see as the fixes you just
mentioned a bunch of holes that they
have
that they they're going to try that that
that would require them to hold on to
their draft choices as opposed to
give them a way to move up for a young
quarterback what do you think they do
and my final question to you here sir i
think rich i think they start on defense
i think you're closer on defense i think
stopping points
is while it's not easy um it'll keep you
in more games you can manage the game on
offense
as the patriots didn't want seven times
with a roster on offense wasn't very
good
but defensively they were getting walked
through so to meet your curious dalvin
tomlinson from the new york giants
since minor williams has been franchised
and then on the edge it's trey
hendrickson
pay those two guys thirteen and a half
sacks for hendrickson last year
you have hightower coming back you have
patrick trump coming back you just you
know you've got a good defense
even if you move on from steph gilmore
via trade which may be another way to
extract a quarterback by the way
then you can go and and try and build
your offense with some heady draft picks
but to me i think free agency might
result could revolve
around where bill feels most comfortable
and that's working on defense
all right i lied to you i have one more
and i know you got to go but uh i got
one more for you
uh can you give me any any insight on
nick casario and what he's thinking
right now
and and how he might play this desean
watson situation that seems to be more
untenable
with each passing day and he and watson
hasn't even opened his mouth yet to a
a member of the nfl media on camera or
his own
social media accounts that could send
this thing spinning in a totally
different direction out of control what
what what is going on in the minds of
of somebody who comes from the patriot
system which might have been the issue
for for watson
and and and what his stance might be
just knowing him at all
tom um i think if you have a new england
bent on things that you do have a
feeling of look you signed a contract
we signed contracts and we respect them
he signed a contract we we expect him to
respect it
but again there comes a point and we saw
it for instance just recently
with michael bennett you've seen it over
the course of time beyond branch even
though six
becomes a point which you have to say
okay that's it you can't do it anymore
it's a distraction the rest of the team
is being bothered by it so
i would imagine they will try to
gingerly talk to watson about staying
but he seems so
solidly dug in not just against the
football team but against the culture
and he's put himself out there so boldly
that you're not going to talk him off
the ledge so there will come a point as
much as they insist otherwise
we're doing what's best for the football
team and getting rid of one of the three
best quarterbacks my estimation in
football
means yeah you'll have to do it don't
you agree
rich you've watched a lot of football
too you know bill i've been saying the
point
yeah i've been saying there's a door and
there's a door b the door a is trying to
make it work
and and door b is uh the godfather offer
that makes
door b far more attractive than the door
a that you really really really want to
make work and you have to essentially
choose door b
over door a and the problem for them is
door a can't be fixed with a contract or
money or security because he's already
got it
you know like that's that's the ultimate
issue here
ferv in the city and you've got to help
the team you're not saying goodbye to
sean watson and there's a massive void
nothing comes back
there's a time where you have to start
investigating okay what's best for the
team and how much can we get back
that will ultimately help us even if
it's [ __ ] to say goodbye to him of
course certainly if you can play two
teams in the same division off each
other and the jets and the dolphins the
bears are desperate and
i mean you know the niners might be
involved in this and but the problem is
is that desean watson on top of all this
holds all the cards because he's got a
no trade clause
he could basically say oh great deal
that you just made with the jets i don't
want to go there
that'll be the end of that yeah you know
i mean so funny you know people up here
like well
why why don't the patriots get in on
what
he wants he wants to come is here where
he's going to have a seat at the table
are you out of your mind anyway
take care of yourself tom thanks for the
call greatly appreciate it all right
thanks for having me you bet uh check
out tom curran on nbc sports boston
and uh follow him on twitter i do hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here